[Musique]
si favorable à la construction d'un
mille places de prison en france parce
que ça répond aux besoins
aux besoins qui sont les nôtres on est
sous dimensionné par rapport à ce que
vous trouvez dans d'autres pays par
rapport à la population carcérale
actuelle et celles qui ne réalisent pas
c'est peine parce qu'il n'ya pas assez
de place donc pour toutes ces raisons je
suis favorable à la construction de
places de prison mais ça veut pas dire
parce qu'on est favorable il faut les
construire n'importe où et n'importe
comment
je pense que
on aurait pu et je pense qu'on devrait
observer ce qui ne peut y avoir on va
dire dans le grand bassin du mantois
l'on se tourne acception là pour voir
s'il n'y a pas d'autres localisations
qui serait plus pertinente je pense que
la localisation en la matière nécessite
qu'il y ait du travail collective de la
concertation avant que de décider
brutalement c'est dans un lieu et pas
dans un autre
je sais que les services les services de
l'état ont des contacts avec les
associations et notamment l'association
tmc paix qui s'est très fortement
mobilisés et très rapidement mobilisés
sur ce sujet et je le comprends et je
sais qu'il ya des échanges j'espère que
ces échanges comment dire non seulement
seront nourries mais qui seront
constructifs
[Musique]